hello everyone and welcome to part two
of my resident evil 8 play-through
um we just went through this house where
a lot of stuff fell down
i think i saw the foot of a lycan
earlier
there's still a lot of noise happening
but at least
it's the brightest part of the game yet
um
i'm less nervous but i don't know that
that's the right call just yet
yeah i think uh like ethan's got a cut
on his hand and the game keeps showing
me
oh oh okay hell am i
well that's pretty
very nice i feel much safer than i did i
don't know
five minutes earlier in this gameplay
session um okay
so i wonder if this will be the bit
that's in the demo maybe
the um the actual village demo rather
than the castle
oh yeah what's that that's not gonna be
nice on you was that it that's a dead
horse
that's a large horn maybe it's not
maybe it looks very stocky
but maybe perspective you know that's
have you considered that
um well okay
i'm looking for my daughter i upped the
brightness because it was too dark
um don't imagine we're gonna find her
anytime soon
my wife got shot oh my god
i don't feel unsafe here for some reason
still
really dark though jeez i'm not entirely
sure if uh
ethan's wife mia is actually dead
despite the fact that she was that's
gonna require a
knife which we do not have yet um she
was shot several times
it was a bit much but i think that maybe
she
isn't dead because she's
you know got the louisiana side effects
which maybe is also a thing for ethan um
okay
is this the room that i came from yes
that's seems good
just a lot of crows mostly
i don't know where to start
it's not like it's an open world game
there's just a lot of
a lot of options out here
is that music
it is music
the sound design man like
they just have things moving so much
even when i don't bump them you know
[Music]
jesus
that's i mean that's a human
okay
okay i'm just passing proof
i don't think there was anything back
here no
i did not love that i was not a huge fan
of that that none of that was good
okay
also i'm sorry if everyone can hear
background noise it's not in the game
okay
well
what could go wrong just me
come and i hang out with all my mates
is that an engine
what happened well i mean somebody
beheaded goats ethan
that's what oh well you mean in terms of
everything being decrepit
that's a different story workshop
ceremony site graveyard okay
oh there are so many like sounds of
fences
okay
the light there would imply that
somebody is in that house
so we're gonna look here first
that shouldn't scare me as much as i did
this is fine okay
cool missing homeowner love that okay
great um
that's some sort of puzzle situation oh
did somebody just walk through that door
did i just see that oh
okay it's fine everything's fine
everything's fine nothing scary nothing
spooky is happening to anyone at all at
any point in time why is it so
dark okay
i would love to slash that box i would
love to
okay well we're gonna take that knife
and we're gonna slash the box
yes good okay already feeling better we
have an inventory
a video game is happening oh the music
this is reminding me far too much of the
dinner table
okay okay they just run out of the house
they may have
why was that a cinematic oh no there's
so much noise
oh no no no no no no
no
okay [ __ ]
i hate this more than anything okay
just it could just be a cut no no
friendly friendly who are you
who sent you nobody there was an
accident
okay great
oh no
they're coming who who's coming who is
who's coming what the hell was that
do you have a gun just this knife that i
stole from you mate
no why would i
i thought he just left me here okay yeah
take it ethan oh my god
hey are you listening hey
think of these
he's gonna say if he's being quiet maybe
there's a reason for that but
oh he uh is an artist up there
who um oh
invited him to start painting maybe
oh there's more dead party that's the
dude you just saw what do you mean a
dead body
surely it is at least
well i mean that's
i mean you guys look cute at least they
you know all snuggled up
wait so i fell through the floor so this
dude just had dead bodies under his
floor
what is this looking
john wayne gacy [ __ ] what is
why you got all these dead bodies down
here dude
unless i'm misunderstanding that okay
what yeah okay interrupt
okay i'd love to yeah let's do it
oh that's the dude i was just jesus
jesus christ
i don't know they look similar
it's just roughly 50-ish
dudes
oh he looks kind of cute actually what's
his deal
how are you that stuffy i don't feel
like you
would know how to do stealth mate i
don't feel like you have that
that ability i don't think like
what the [ __ ] was that oh buddy okay
well
um ethan uh no
no no no okay okay okay okay this is
ethan
oh no oh no oh my okay okay okay
oh oh oh no no no i panicked and i shot
badly
just every time i should be guarding as
well it did tell me to just do that just
oh that worked dude could you leave me
alone
oh my god how many shots do you take is
that it please be dead
please just don't get back up
okay i need to change my triggers they
are
entirely too hot nope
that was an accident my bad no that's
still not right
there we go okay
um okay uh so um
well that's a lichen my hand is
probably in a lot of trouble here is all
i'm going to
address um that seems oh i should heal
maybe as well
that's why um yeah we should uh we
should take that
we should take that i don't know that
that's gonna
jesus this is gonna work there dude
okay
okay great crafting
can i take those that seems like a good
time i'm just trying to out of trouble
apple's shattered like glass
um okay oh yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
we can combine these two things can we
not
beautiful
thank you cool
and then maybe we nope
six um all right can i get through this
gate
i can't believe that didn't work um all
right i'm gonna find somewhere else to
go
okay well you guys will just go back out
this way then
oh great oh got them way earlier than
i'm used to getting anything like that
i need to do that just open the gate it
will open the wall clutters for us
when we do it okay excellent
okay
is that from me
i mean this seems like it would have
been a really nice place at some point
huge bummer
huge bummer keep getting me with like
half open doors also
music question mark is back to seriously
just so much sound design happening
we get it you designed the sound
what is that
oh i hate that the most oh that's
that's the [ __ ] worst okay oh a boot
hello there
fine it's not like i didn't know it
wanted me to go in the house i just
didn't want to do it
oh
yeah it's holiday
why not right okay
cool um can i break that oh it's open
just the worst thing i've ever heard
stop please
stop when i got near it that's the
scariest thing that's happened in a
video game ever
the [ __ ] sound design dude
just just stare even just a snap just
just just step nobody's worried about it
it's kim flew it you love that it's one
of your favorite [ __ ]
okay hey hello just trying to take the
hang of it
thank you okay cool great no nope i'm
happy here actually um
what the [ __ ]
oh oh oh i see oh okay oh god where from
i oh
oh no no no no no no no no no no no
okay cool um
quite overwhelmed right now shoulders
okay um okay can i get can i get through
this way somehow oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh no oh no no no no no
terrible terrible terrible aim it's not
going to fare well for us here where did
you are you the one who came from the
[ __ ] roof or whatever
stay down [ __ ]
i did fix my shooting issues though um
okay yeah i'll take that okay well for
where do i go from
here where do i go is it back upstairs
is there a way out up here now
is it over
i doubt it buddy i think i think it's
where does this [ __ ] radio get off
hello
survivors out there come to my okay
near the field i'd love to survivors
yeah i'd love to that'd be great
okay how
[ __ ] noises man um i still don't know
how to get through here though or out of
here
not this way i bet you there's some door
i'm missing because it's so
freaking dark maybe i'm supposed to go
back out
they might uh open that little side door
or something now
okay
this is the way i came it is right
that's no that's chill
they're gonna be hunting me out here oh
but
okay no it's fine it's cool we are
cool don't want to hang out with anybody
actually
[ __ ]
g'day mate yeah just no it's cool you
just back it up you just
you just leave that'll be yeah just a
bit further back and then i'll come
forward and
i'll i'll get the box yeah that's good
that's good
or are they is the ai doing that to to
jump scare me
this is my follow-up question
did you do that to be mean or did you do
that
like because you were just kind of on
that path you know
just trying to get a hub everybody chill
out
everybody's fine
being in a different area to me nobody's
panicked about it
oh [ __ ]
why are you telling me to run why i'm
trying to grab the shotgun i'd really
like to grab this shotgun
okay okay take that and we'll go
downstairs we will go
downstairs [ __ ]
what's this i love scraps that's that's
my favorite thing
oh my god who taught them
how to be this stealthy i'm gonna have a
bad time
do i have enough ammo to kill them all
is the question i don't know that i do
um okay do i have a map
i do okay that's where i came from i
assume
i don't know where survive the attack oh
i'm just supposed to survive right now
so there's all these [ __ ] locked
gates
oh [ __ ]
you say i've not explored this house huh
i have not explored whatever that is oh
that's what i'm currently searching
unexplored is gray
[ __ ] it okay
i just go for that house i think maybe
oh i don't know where to go i do love
breaking a box though hang on everybody
just give me a second please just get i
just said give me a second
he's supposed to [ __ ] hell
okay and this is gonna be locked great
okay oh god oh god how how did you [ __ ]
about emma
uh i didn't know you got back up i
didn't know you got back up and frankly
i think it's rude that you did
okay okay uh uh uh no no
get down and stay down oh i pressed the
block button
that okay well okay now hey okay i have
to [ __ ] run i'm not gonna make it
through this
okay all right indy no leave me alone
leave me alone leave me alone i'm just
trying to get out of here
to go find the nice lady from the
slightly creepy radio
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is not
a good time oh my god oh my god oh my
god okay break that
what's in it go upstairs
i don't know that i made the right call
i maybe made the wrong call maybe this
was not the right
place to come okay
it's a waste of [ __ ] ammo [ __ ] where
do i go where do i go where do i go
they're everywhere oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] no leave me alone leave me alone
i should really wait for the reticle to
come back i know that
that's another box right there i don't
even notice can you climb
oh they can climb that's great that's
great that's great no no that's not bad
i just jumped down
just give me a second so i can do this
please thank you okay now go
go
away
okay maybe i can jump this okay cool
right into him [ __ ] okay i need no
that's not
right why i need help i need help i need
help i need help
okay cool okay good day
uh up up up
[ __ ] hell man i don't know where i'm
going did i just i just went in a circle
i can't have surely i can't have but i
but i did but alas i did
[ __ ] there's so many of them okay okay
okay
one over here and then you just go this
way this time
[ __ ] that's where i started
it's gonna be locked it's gonna be
locked isn't it great of course it is
okay i can't go any further that way
oh oh oh hello large one oh my
you are big okay what am i gonna do here
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
is this is this is this a pop is this a
path [ __ ] off
oh you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't even know what i'm guarding from
[ __ ] i don't know
oh my god you're too big you are you are
too large oh he's right behind me
okay okay this is fine this is fine this
is fine it's fine
uh just [ __ ]
running around in circles [ __ ]
okay that seems like it was supposed to
happen maybe or or maybe not
no [ __ ] hell
oh my god
oh is that really meant to happen
keep getting worse
hey bud hello okay hey yes i saw you
okay
it's a cool hammer though it's very
overwatch i
actually kind of like it okay well
you're actually a bit cool
i'm not mad
is that savior is that is that help
yeah i scared you with my bravery
and perseverance
okay great working um that's a bummer
uh your hand is falling apart
but otherwise we feel very positively
about this experience
oh no
okay cool
this is the witch from the demo you are
you helping are you here to help
does she have magic to close gates
behind her and put locks on them no they
stay oh
i will shoot you old lady
okay hello hi there hey
[Music]
in life and in death we give glory
totally uh hello
you shouldn't be out here it's not safe
i think she might know it better than
you about paddy pig
can you hear me he's a bit mansplainy
the child's fat
hey wait do you mean rose is she here
rose
rose yes she is in great danger well
yeah
since mother miranda brought her to the
village we have fallen into
darkness what are you talking about the
monsters
you're saying my baby some monsters
that's what you're trying to tell me
well harold's danger
they're coming she is very
where's rose cartoon villain
[Laughter]
this is why i don't hang out with old
people
what's that noise so this is the demo
area
which is why that noise just concerned
me because they i mean it's entirely
possible that they've made things
different from
this part of the demo right i guess
we'll see
this room looks pretty much the same
yeah cool uh shrine
huge fan very nice stuff
okay
i wonder if that's how the lycans will
be the whole time like
they just show up and then disappear
sort of whenever
this is probably locked
um okay
and i don't think i can get in here also
locked
i think i had to go up this way um this
is gonna need a crank
yeah okay
we will wow
at me go thank you appreciate that thank
you for the 15g
and it means a lot to me this is also
locked okay
yeah this is the seals we're looking for
and if i remember correctly i went this
way
yep that's the first one
that's right okay should disaster fall
upon the village seek out the crests one
is in the care of the church the other
is it
louise's house okay yeah we knew all
this
um here's that last save
very nice
okay i'm gonna just put it back in
just because i like to stay on top of
this stuff
there you go love beautiful
i think i just keep going through
this way up i think actually
no this is where i went last time okay
so i don't think i can go up here yet
this is gonna be locked correct
um so i go through here and there are
going to be more of them
and i am kind of of the opinion that
with the lichens
for the most part it's not necessarily
worth fighting them
because they are strong
it's possible they only take two
headshots though i'm not actually sure
about it yet
yeah i hear you music okay i understand
very scared yes yes yes
i know yeah
that's what i get for condescending the
video game i'm really sorry about
all that you i'm scared i am scared i
take all of the pretending i was doing
i'm definitely actually scared
a little bit um
i just want to go for that box and the
good news is that i know that i can run
from them if i need to
as it turns out ethan can take a lot
he is resilient
and then there's another thing to grab
that's like to the over to
over to over here on the other side of
this i think
oh oh boy oh my oh my
i've just orientated myself again oh
[ __ ]
nope nope it wasn't through here because
it was locked
right through the house somewhere yeah
that's right yep
hello yeah oh go
this one needs me to press a
okay what are you doing here
hey i'm cool man stay back please
don't hurt us whoa it's okay
i'm not gonna hurt you i'm just glad to
see normal people at last
why is everyone gonna they're survivors
american accent out here
they're all in louise's house and she's
not answering in the gate is locked
quiet he's an outsider
yeah which means i can help you guys
clearly have [ __ ] us all up pretty bad
okay [ __ ] we're setting ducks in here
can your old man walk
no clearly sometimes outside is good
he's lost a lot of blood yeah well i
lost two fingers
okay i think he'll be fine with a cut
must be a way inside
stay here be quiet don't move until i
get those gates open
check your privilege dude you gotta cut
your [ __ ] friend that's pretty bad
cough
i'm sorry i'm sorry that wasn't
sensitive
okay nope
um it was climb it was climb
take gunpowder maybe i should do some
crafting
craft first aid and then we'll cross
some handgun
and we'll leave it at that beautiful
lovely
can't do anything here i remember
correctly
right nothing happens right
strange pick that up
to be fair as the outsider the fact that
i am running around just wielding a
knife probably ocean i do need to heal
running around wielding a knife probably
is pretty scary
um to anyone who would see me but i'm
not putting it away
hello
oh that's right i do need to get them
inside first don't i just have to open
the gate from
this side can't forget about the people
we are trying
to help right
come on it's clear hurry you just you
just gotta cut dude i lost two fingers
today
and my wife and probably my baby who i
think i'm probably gonna have to fight
as a giant demon later
you got scratched
okay he's not used to relying on other
people
i'm sorry we'll be safe in here
won't we i don't know see if we're here
who even is louisa i don't [ __ ] know
these people
hey do you know anything about you are
probably cultists and i don't think that
that doesn't make any sense
miranda has always protected us nobody's
answered
father
we have to get inside okay
hello hello anybody home
maybe a familiar voice louisa
open up it's me elena
stop shouting you'll draw the monsters
he is right
who's this a friend stay back father
for god's sake julian let us in uh no
they'll smell the blood you'll endanger
us all
my father will die out here that's not
my problem what's going on gosh
these people want to let a dying man
into our home come now these people
are our friends go on go inside come now
this way you're not from this village
no no may as well be though we all have
the same accent somehow julian go make
yourself useful and check the grounds
i said go
well if elena trusts you
and so do i come inside ethan
it is pretty nice of her i wouldn't [ __ ]
with this dude at all
okay wait here i'll check on the other
perfect as is
was with this part of the demo i'm going
to save
and i'm going to steal your stuff i hope
that that is ok
don't worry about it
great um
i think that was it okay cool yeah hey
sure
gonna paint these walls go
also what is with this town come inside
the other people having
doors that have drapes over them
outsiders you're going to get us all
killed anton
he helped leonardo and elena we were
doing fine by ourselves
please ethan take a seat thank you how
about if i do
is this all that's left from your entire
village all that's left
all that's left there is no one left
a worthless invalid
a stupid whaling [ __ ]
and you you drag a bloody man and an
outsider in here like it's nothing and
expect to be all safe
there is no safe every
sorry bastard out there has been ripped
in half
but tomorrow
tomorrow we'll all be dead
just like a damn husband you didn't have
to do it like that what a
roxanna that's enough this house has
protected my family for generations
and drunk or not you are all welcome
and safe in here whatever
can someone please tell me what the hell
is going on here
we don't know one day we were a quiet
devout village and the next the monsters
came
and attacked us i think the [ __ ]
mocap is so good they kept coming wait
louise
where is your husband did they
no no he he is out there
somewhere it's a good performance he he
went to get help
yes yes that's that's it he he went to
fetch help
hmm let us pray
for him for all of us good idea
come gather
are you single because i might be
looking for a new wife
great ones elena's boys
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings
did you do a little dance no oh the tea
should be ready
yeah he's got a bad boy please
that prayer everybody has really been
through some [ __ ] near the graveyard
a [ __ ] as crazy as a bag of rats
there is wisdom in her devotion though
and i hope it protected her as it shows
she's fine
you guys are not
the old lady is doing great great cool
yeah
for us leonardo what's wrong are you
okay
life comes at you fast man it really
really does come out fast okay hello
hello
honey because she's hot cause we try not
hey i have i have a whole future plan
with you
[Applause]
[Music]
probably shouldn't even try i'm also so
self-conscious right now that i'm saying
the same things that i said when i
played through the spot of the demo
which is entirely possible i've done
that before
later i said
no ouch
oh my god i'm so sorry father okay let's
go it's a burning building you're super
hot
anymore we can't lose
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
all right you couldn't save him he was
already gone
leave me alone no we're getting out of
here you don't know her
chill dude don't touch a lady you have
five minutes ago on the shoulder like
that
um okay i don't remember exactly what i
did
i do have to get out of here though yes
i think we went upstairs
did i look for a key or something i
think i found a key in the kitchen
this way oh hello hub
yeah we're on some speed run business
right now
what no okay
screwdriver out of the key ring if you
need it
right uh
beautiful
uh-huh i think that was all that was in
here
yes yes yes good good good good good and
then
cracky the fight's moving fast uh-huh
truckee let's roll
what are you thinking step back could
you just drive out of halo stop with
this
i don't know that i ever would have
thought of this you know
because i'm not sure it's a good idea
generally don't think the strategy
would work
there's a photo mode that exists even in
cinematics
that's cool are you all right doing
great thank you i'm fine
let me back up again the fire there
isn't any time
okay let's probably go upstairs
grab on hurry
let's move go go go go go go go
and try not to breathe in the smoke i
know
thank you ethan
i don't feel like when i played this bit
i did i didn't expect it to be
safe i do too doubt it i didn't expect
it to be this early in the game
there that's our way out oh thank god
a window but what then who could have
seen her coming
full of monsters it's true yeah we can't
fight them there's too
many hey hey don't talk like that she's
right also again ethan you don't know
her
my hunch is she's in that old castle no
the place is full of nothing but blood
and death
and i don't want to be alone while
you're father
don't come back buddy that's not him not
anymore
it kind of sounds like they're saying my
name father
maybe she lives maybe maybe she doesn't
stay there
i don't fire death come on give me your
hand
ethan go save your daughter
twice
is everyone dying on me
i still think the strategy was really
bad just going higher
and buildings on fire is a bad idea you
should have found a way out
so some of it's on you but with a little
more context
i just don't get it you probably
shouldn't i don't
the car was a weird choice i i feel like
you have some blame
you've got to be a little bit
accountable for this
this place has gone mad
how would you know you never saw it
beforehand because it's happening again
okay that's fair i'm still from
louisiana's situation
he's had a rough go of it is what i'll
say he's not had
an easy ride over the last five years
all right screwdriver
yes and then i will take that
and i will take it
yes great
it's a hot laugh though
well he said out loud even he said
mother miranda he said stop
mother miranda it was they i don't know
that they could have made it more
obvious for you buddy
there was something to pick up here in
the demo that's why i came there we go
that's me just trying to get my rusted
scripts
um all right i'm gonna go do the thing i
couldn't do
in the demo because i ran out of time
hell yeah dude
[Laughter]
this is definitely going to be me when
i'm older look it up
yeah i am about that can i open this
with a screwdriver
negative all right
i can't do anything with that yet no
it's my favorite death block song um all
right i'm gonna put the thing in here
that seems that seems good yeah
very exciting i never went up that way
though this is gonna be locked right
let's
take a look again
my favorite uh death metal band
okay that is left yeah all right
i just want to see what's through here
oh i guess this is like castle
hot chicks yeah there's sex enough to
hit the plot button
what are you where you swimming to ethan
buddy what are you swimming to
all right i think
okay we made it
to the castle
this place is cool this is a weird
entrance though maybe this isn't the
main entrance
because nobody has those two emblems
all right well well
didn't think anyone was left you must be
pretty tough huh
who the [ __ ] are you yes that oh
you're not local even better
mother miranda is going to love you
he's cool
but he also said miranda
oh this was in the showcase but i would
like to ask him
about the miranda thing
the man is of no real use to anyone else
and my daughters do
so love entertaining foreign
[Music]
where you mean you'll screw around with
them in private where's the fun in that
give them to me i just developed on the
show that everybody can enjoy
oh so gauche what do we care for bread
and circuses
the man thinks suffering is assured yeah
cause a man's dick is cut off in the
castle blah blah
that's what you want to do with me i'm
all right with it i've heard all your
arguments
some of you were less persuasive than
others but
i've made my decision heisenberg
the man's fate is in your hands mother
miranda i must protest
heisenberg is but a child and his
devotion to you is questionable
give the mortal to me and i will ensure
he
is ready shut your damn he's cool though
you're the one who's arguing with
miranda's decision responsibility if it
was wealthy
oh keep glory one day your head will
actually fit your ego
this is very weird my decision
is final there will be no argument
remember thanks
at least my dick's not getting cut off
but oh she's lycans
and gentlemen you know they talk about
the titty but they don't talk about it
the games begin
the bitty she also has huge
fit
get ready i would actually just like to
save
has anybody oh my
has anybody seen a typewriter anywhere
actually
um because that's i'm just after a
typewriter
oh god oh my god okay okay okay okay
okay jesus christ yeah but
run for your life i'm actually just
running for a typewriter
are any of you like poets or anything
like anyone here
like a huge fan of uh pros
um very nice
you written any short stories lately or
anything anyone cause i
um oh a big guy i just think he's cool
okay i don't want that for me but i
still think he's cool
hey so do you happen to
got any screenplays that you've written
recently and
if so on what technology did you write
it
that's pretty cool
[Applause]
great you're still alive
thank you hey if you know of any way
that i could write about this
um it is
um that would be that would be sick if
there was like a location where maybe i
could write down some thoughts on
this situation which has impressed you
so
[Applause]
oh the ceiling's coming down oh that's
what's happening behind me
oh well i'm fine oh
jeez my word
you truly are as strong as they say
they've been talking about me
this is still happening i'm just trying
to oh [ __ ] oh my god
oh no oh now it's time for the beautiful
well
this is going to kill me
nothing like fresh american ground beef
didn't kill me
that's good
okay okay okay
cool um wait do those freaks have rows
i just want to say that i feel like some
positives came out of this
that maybe lady d has been talking about
me
and um
and it's still really dark and i'm ju
and i got to talk to some friends about
their creative
uh literacy
okay okay okay what
[ __ ] she wasn't wrong about the death
this place is like really
death metal band heaven okay
no that's just bars all right let's go
i sure did is this back at the start
it is but now this is openable maybe
is he just gonna teleport her again i
don't know he's basically a superhero so
i don't really know what the situation
with this man is
like i'm not entirely sure how to
address the literal superhero
okay interesting
we're back outside hmm
okay okay
uh this is um a very unique resident
evil so far i think
i'm sure that they'll tie it into the
universe
um outside of obviously like me and
ethan
and now rose but um
that doesn't seem oh okay
i've been waiting for you mr winter
hello
cutie how do you know my name do you
want to give him anyone who is anyone
has heard of the likes of you
a hero searching for his daughter
though i must say that castle arouses
suspicion
it does yes yeah and so do you
sick by anything nice nice dunk donuts
here oh forgive my manners
call me the duke now to business weapons
ammunition healing salves anything you
desire
the ability to save
ah yes yes i probably have had an over
auto save at some point
i've procured some new items for you mr
winter
well i can afford a little bit of that
what is that high capacity mag
recipe mines sniper ammo shotgun emma
i'd love that i'm pretty poor right now
though
shotgun i already have those two and
smithy
weapon upgrades oh i can't afford
anything well then i'm gonna say let's
just buy the
the one thing we can't afford a couple
of times
there we go an interesting selection
great
pay me no mine okay thank you for your
patronage
i really like him i'm a huge fan
all right let's keep rolling
okay typewriter anywhere
typewriter hmm
could rose be here i think that's pretty
likely ethan my dude i think if she was
gonna be anywhere
it would be here three daughters bella
cassandra and daniella
all very cute okay the lighting in here
is wonderful
redneck delivery of one male three
females having a random meeting with
dimitrovsky
or dimitrisk the duke business
discussions
okay that's somebody's schedule
i don't know that i want to go that way
yet that looks spooky
i have to okay cool
great a lot of boots laying around
whoever did the art for that boot design
really they really got utilized
okay
it feels a little bit weird to be so
unsettled in a place that's like this
pristine
okay cool keep going
anybody well that looks like the main
hole which makes me think i should go
back
it's fine
okay let's
it's gonna be locked anyways yeah all
right
well that wasn't my child screaming i'll
tell you that much
okay
ah that's what i was looking for
all right i'm going to leave it there
everyone thank you all for joining me
on um part two
of my resident evil 8 livestream lynch
playthrough
i'm interested and excited and having
fun so far that's my hot take
i'll see you guys next time bye